okay so on top of the amazing phase five  announcement we've also had some amazing  news dropped at comic-con hall h san  diego 2022. did i say that in the right  order probably not but i'm very hyped  now kevin feige took to the stage and  not only did he announce the upcoming  plans for the first phase he also went  into what's going to be happening in  phase six this will be titled the  multiverse saga and it will start with  fantastic four dropping november 8th  2024 from here we're going to go into  avengers kang dynasty and then finish up  with avengers secret war in theaters  november 7th 2025 lots of major  announcements coming out of the event  that i'll definitely keep on top of and  i hope that you're enjoying the video so  far if you missed our quick phase 5  update then definitely go check it out  as it'll be linked on screen right now  thanks